Speaker 1: I want to talk a little bit about this
idea of asking questions. Now, we've talked before
about how I'm just asking questions is sometimes
used to create cover for bad faith questions,
destructive questions, corrosive questions,
pushed questions, like, for example, listen,
I'm just asking questions. If Democrats continue
their communist murder campaign of Republicans,
would you still vote for them? Guys. I'm just
asking questions. You're not going to tell me
questions are bad, are you? We've seen it used
in that way. But I want to mention something else
about question and questions, and it relates to
our friend Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson.
Asking questions in and of itself isn't virtuous.
Isn't virtuous asking obviously stupid, ridiculous
questions meant merely to fire up low information
voters isn't something we should celebrate. But
Tucker is increasingly using this meme questions
What are we no longer allowed to ask questions in
the United States? As he likes to laugh as if.
Speaker 2: Everybody is
free to ask questions about.
Speaker 1: It and demand real answers.
Speaker 2: If you're. Coming up with some sort
of crazy theory about what happened at Nancy
Pelosi's House last Friday. Instead of yelling
at you or calling you names or telling you your
conspiracy nut, you're Alex Jones. Just produce
the police body cam. Why is that so hard? If you
think something weird was going on on January 6th.
Okay, it's not your fault. Maybe it's the fault of
the people hiding thousands of hours of video.
Speaker 1: Or maybe the fault of the people
telling you something weird went on when anyone's.
Speaker 2: From January 6th.
Speaker 1: Why would they release that?
The onus is on them, not the rest of us.
Speaker 2: We're not the crazy people. You're the.
Speaker 1: Liars. Okay. So a couple of different
things there. Tucker fundamentally misunderstands
burden of proof. If you are going to make a claim,
like, for example, a claim that's been made
many times, there was fraud in multiple states
organized by different people in each state,
significant enough that the true winner,
if it represented the will of the voters,
would have been Trump instead of Biden.
It's up to you if you believe that instead
of an obviously politically motivated right
wing attack on the Pelosi household in San
Francisco last week, what took place was
a lover's quarrel between Paul Pelosi and his gay
prostitute who was already inside the House at
the time of the altercation. You need to produce
that evidence. You need to produce statements. But
let's put aside burden of proof. We shouldn't
fall for the absurd notion that bad faith,
absurd questions should be celebrated because
in a vacuum, asking questions is a good thing.
I think we're dealing mostly with adults, at
least legally, to a three year old. You might
want to encourage curiosity and all that. And you
say there's never a stupid question. Always. I
want to hear every single one of your questions.
Oh, it's a beautiful thing to a six year old when
they ask a silly question, you might say, that's
such a silly question. Let me tell you why. To
a ten year old, you might say, hey, you know
what? Let's focus our questions up to build on
what we already know. You know that there's some
questions that are useful and some questions that
are just nonsense. But to adults, you would say
cut the stupid questions, you imbeciles. It is
neither good nor righteous to make up so-called
evidence out of the blue claim that now it is the
default official story we should believe and
then ask other people to disprove your crazy
ideas. The immediate assumption should be Why
is that? The question at this point in time,
where is the burden of proof? Does the evidence
actually fit that being the question and being
put in the position all the time by these folks
to prove negatives the way they love to do?
It's not virtuous. It's not to be admired. It's
simply nonsense. And so let's not fall for there's
no such thing as stupid or silly questions.
There are. What you say to a kid about questions
is different than what you might say to Tucker
Carlson or to these MAGA people. Keep it in mind.